[Music]
let's get started
my name is Matthew I'm actually on the
Android studio platform team that means
I work on things like product stability
call integration and one of the most
exciting things that gets worked on
besides park stability is something
called androids and just knots what I'm
here to talk about you with you today so
Android lint is actually a very powerful
tool I think a lot of you already know
about it but you might not know all the
cool things I can do so despite the name
it's not just a linting tool it's
actually like a full-fledged static
analysis framework and it's really
powerful you can write your own checks
and I'm going to talk about that today
this talk is really for anyone kind of
really interested in programming
languages compilers static analysis it's
also for anyone who has had to deal with
bugs in the project so I think that
covers the rest of you oh yeah one last
thing I only have 20 minutes but there's
a lot of material so I'm gonna go kind
of fastest on these slides try to keep
up the good news is that at the end of
the day you can go home you can watch on
the house speed on YouTube and you
should build on Stan's phone with it
then all right let's get started
I'm gonna go actually fast now so let's
keep up all right so what are the
entrants like I said are you a lot of
you party already know even if you don't
know the name you actually do know what
enter lint is because it's the thing
that shows up warning messages in your
ID is saying hey you're doing something
wrong and so in some cases this is like
telling you hey Gradle might be out of
date you want to update it
or maybe you're not calling a super
method and a method that expects you to
do so and right in Android studio and
the ID it'll say hey there's some Co
here look suspicious maybe you want to
take a look and sometimes it's morning
sometimes it's errors that will actually
fail the build so some of you might not
know but it's actually a lot of
different ways to use enter Lintz first
one is on the fly which is what I just
mentioned where it's kind of in the ID
as its type being it shows error
messages right away you can also use
something called an inspector code this
is an action in Android studio where you
can run a batch analysis of your entire
project it's a really great way to kind
of audit your project for common common
errors and a related action called one
inspection by name so if you have a
particular bug in mind say you want to
find a lot of like thread annotation
violations
you can run that inspection by name kind
of audit your entire projects in one
batch analysis and look this one by one
some of you might not know actually
though that you can also run lint at the
command line for with Gradle so you just
something like Gradle lint debug that's
one of the tasks that we have it's kind
of the same thing it'll just do a batch
analysis for your entire project and the
really great thing about that is it'll
make a HTML and XML report so you can
parse the XML report if you want to do
something fancy with the results or you
can just take a look at the HTML report
and go through your you know warnings so
even if you know what any lint is I
really want to do a deep dive into kind
of the advanced use cases for four lanes
because it's a very powerful tool so
first I'm just gonna talk about
configuration kind of sounds boring but
it's actually really important for big
projects you want to make sure Android
lint is working for your project and for
your needs also going to talk about
annotations it's a really powerful way
to kind of markup your code to help lint
help you even more so kind of lint
automatically does as much as it can but
sometimes you need to tell it hey you
need to give it hints to help you even
more also gonna talk about lint
internals I'm really excited for this
part because I really want to give you a
good mental model for how work lint
works under the hood this will get you
set up for kind of realizing how
powerful of a tool it is and also for
writing your own custom in checks which
is actually the last step and that's
kind of the fun demo part all right so
let's talk about configuration the
easiest way to kind of see what lint is
capable of is to go in see you and your
studio open up preferences go to the
inspections window you'll kind of find a
heading that says lint and under there
you can see all of the inspections that
lint has there's actually hundreds and
most of them are enabled by default but
there's actually some that are not
checked by default and I encourage you
to kind of just explore these take a
look at them because some of these might
actually apply to your project even
though we don't enable button by default
a really good example of this is
something called call an
interoperability this is just a set of
checks that we created so that you can
call Java code from calling code and
vice versa
and if you do things that makes that
difficult then lint will actually warn
you right in the IDE like hey you might
wanna rename this function so that it's
easier to call from the other language
there's actually another way to
configure lint which is with
gradle so if you go and see your
build.gradle file you have this Android
block as you know but you can also add a
lint options block and there's some
really powerful options here so this
first option I'm going to go through a
few examples this first option here is a
really powerful tool anyone with a
really big project you really want to
pay attention to this so Allen's
baseline is just kind of like when you
add this to your options Lynch will take
a snapshot of all of the warnings and
errors you currently have in your
project and what this will do is they'll
give you a clean slate so you'll say
like hey I want to take a baseline at
this point of the project and forget
about all of the thousands of learnings
that I already have and then I only want
to look at new warnings and errors
coming in in new code that my team
checks in and this is kind of helps you
get a handle on like the massive amount
of code that you have and still be able
to have clean code going forward and
then when you have more time free time
you can go back and look at all the
baseline issues that lint has stashed
away once you do that so once you have a
clean slate either to a lint baseline or
because you have a new project and you
just want to say hey I want to have
clean code forever starting now you can
turn on warnings as errors I really
encourage you to try this out it might
not be for everyone but you kind of up
clean code definitely try to try to get
this to work for you and then like in
the last slide you can able specific
checks that are not on by default like
interoperability so some of you already
have this lens options block set up and
some more advanced things I want to talk
about is performance issues so one of
the reasons we have this lens options
block in Gradle is because a lot of
people run lint on their continuous
integration server and so they're
constantly checking their entire
application for lint warnings lint
there's maybe they even block presubmit
if you have a new warning that someone
just checked in but some people are kind
of concerned about performance so just a
few tips here real quick try to avoid
the checkout warnings option I know it's
really tempting I just told you how to
enable more checks but actually some of
the checks are off by defaults for
performance reasons for example so
if you took all warning it's like
because I oh man my my time to check the
project is doubled but be a little bit
more selective in the checks that you
turn on also try to avoid the Gradle
lint tasks there's it's actually a
parent task of multiple sub tasks one of
which is like lint debug or lint release
the the parent lint task will actually
run Lintz multiple times on our project
for each build variance and so that's
just a really simple gotchu that you
should try to avoid also if you can use
the ignore test sources option so by
default we already don't look at your
test sources for warnings there's the
theory being that you don't really care
about how clean your tests are but this
option will actually make us we don't
even parse your your test sources at all
and so presumably all of you have really
really well tested code so this option
will help with that and make things go
faster
all right let's switch gears a bit I
want to talk about annotations
annotations are a really powerful way to
just give lint hints for specific issues
that you want to look for so I'm just
gonna go for a few examples a lot of you
already know about the null ability
annotations hopefully to use this a lot
in Java and Colleen you don't need them
because it's kind of built into the
language but we also have really Android
specific annotations which you should
check out so there's one call the
requires permission you probably know
about this one too but it's just an
example where we kind of annotate
certain eight Android API is with
requires permission maybe you like to
set wallpaper permission and then lint
will actually kind of do some analysis
on the code that calls into this API and
say hey is the programmer actually
checking that they have this permission
if they don't then we can warn you like
hey it looks like you haven't checked
that you have this permission this might
crash at runtime and this this this
impacts users quite a bit there's also
one of my favorites
kind of annotations which is UI thread
and worker thread annotations I think
there is called thread annotations in
general these are really important
actually so a lot a big problem with
application development is you know a
lot of you
frameworks require that you only update
the UI on a single thread called the UI
thread and everything else has to be
done the background debts if you do
network requests if you're on background
thread because if you do it on the UI
thread you know the network requests
might block you'll freeze UI user will
be frustrated you might not even see a
crash report and it's really hard to
track down those issues so we have these
thread annotations where you can say hey
this method should only be called on the
UI thread or should only be called on a
worker thread and we have some analyses
to to track that down so I'm actually I
do a demo of these analyses
hopefully that's set up so switch over
we switch over to the demo perfect
awesome
so you should imagine I should have it
here I'm going to go through an example
this is just calling let's say we have a
function
oh it's screen is black you're right
awesome
let's good started so let's say wave
function called update UI obviously
expect this to be run on the UI thread
so maybe this is updating the user
interface whatever you want and then
let's say we also a function called
Network requests oh it's a really
contrived example and you know this does
some stuff all right
and unfortunately someone decided to
call a network request from the update
UI method so this is a problem right as
you can see there's no errors of warning
and starting issues like this is
actually really hard to track down in
general but if you know about these
thread annotations you can add the UI
thread here you can add to work with
thread annotation here and instantly
lint will say hey you're trying to make
a network request on a UI thread that
can freeze DUI you don't want to do that
so that's really really powerful I
really encourage you to use these now
you might be thinking hey like this is a
really contrived example this is too
simple actually what we have in our
application is the CY method that calls
the function foo maybe and then that
function calls something called bar and
then that bar function calls for network
requests there's just like multiple
layers of indirection
you're thinking oh like Linds can't help
us here right and as you can see it
cants right right it defaults because
for performance reasons we don't try to
do these advanced analyses but actually
we do have an analysis for this so I'm
going to show you an example of that you
can do run inspection by name
the the name of the instruction is
called the wrong thread and then
interpret interprocedural if you select
that it's like the scope will just say
module scope and bam it'll find the call
path from from foo - to barter network
request I know you can't see this every
message on here so let me copy it for
you and I'll remove the class names and
so you can see the error message shows
you hey you're starting update UI you're
going to fool your going to bar and then
they go into network request and that's
annotated with raka thread and that's an
issue all right let's go back to the
slides so please check those out that
analysis is off by default for the main
reason being performance it's trying to
do a whole program analysis it's a
pretty expensive so just you know use it
when you can just try it out and see if
it finds any bugs in application alright
so next time I talk about lint internals
this parts really cool so the way the
way lint works is it starts out with
parsing your source files so maybe have
some Java Cartland lying around kind of
bills the abstract syntax tree and the
first thing we do with that is we
actually wrap it in something called u
ast just stands for universal abstract
insect syntax tree if you've dealt with
these kind of things before that might
sound I'm pretty familiar but this step
is really important because it means
that when you write a check you don't
have to read it once and it works on
both Java and Collin and that's that's
really convenient actually and then when
you write a lint analysis you're
actually just operating directly on you
ast so when you write a yet Lynch check
you're just kind of scanning the you ast
for your source code you're looking for
method calls that you're interested in
you're looking in expressions that
you're interested in and that's how it
works it's also important to point out
lint actually works also on all
types of files so you can you can look
at Gradle files you can look at XML
files and resources this is actually
really powerful because it kind of gives
us a holistic view of your entire
application and we can provide a lot
more helpful of warning messages with
that a couple more points here so type
information is available it's not just
you're not just looking at text you
actually have the whole ast with type
information you do things like method
resolution you can do things like
examining the class hierarchy of the of
the class you're looking at that's
really important for preventing false
positives and just having really
powerful link checks that's kind of what
makes Lyn so so useful we also have
really tight integration with the IDE so
one of my favorite parts about lint is
that you know it actually does show you
the warning messages right in the IDE I
think that's critical because if you
don't have that then a lot of your
morning messages would just be lost in
some build up but somewhere and it
wouldn't be useful to most people so
with that we're gonna move into writing
custom lint checks and what this means
is that you know Android lint is
actually a framework you can write your
own lint checks if you're something that
annoys you like either a common bug that
you run into you and your team or just
something that you want your colleagues
to watch out for you can write your own
Lin check you can upload it to your
codebase and all your colleagues will
see it any ID things highlighted quick
note here lint actually has an unstable
API all this means is that we don't
promise that we keep it the same from
release to release the good news is that
it's not changing too often but no
promises the other good news is that
unstable API is not really fun to play
with so all right and with that we're
gonna move into the demo so let's switch
over awesome
much faster this time all right so don't
bother reading code too much the example
I want to set up here is that you see
that your colleagues are maybe calling
thread yields pretty often and if you
look at the documentation for the thread
yield it's actually not a very useful
method I mean you know if you're writing
very advanced concurrent data structures
maybe it's useful but in other cases you
really want to avoid it usually doesn't
do what you think it does so let's say
we want to write our own Lin check that
actually catches calls to threads out
yields and once people that they're
doing that
so right now it's not highlighted
there's no Lin checks yet I want to show
you how I have this set up so you
already have some kind of a droid
application module here here it's just
called app the way you're going to write
your own Lin checks is all you're going
to do is you're going to make a Java
module may be called checks for example
and you're going to add a dependency
from your Android application to the the
checks module and we have this nice lint
checks block here which will make it
really easy to do that once you have
that set up and I know I'm going to skip
I'm skipping over some of the details
here but I'm gonna have some links at
the end I can look at sample projects so
once you have that set up we can
actually go right to the lint check
itself so here of a class called yield
detector as you can imagine this is a
detector for calls to thread yields
extends some classes in the lint
framework and I already have typed up
some some of the metadata for this check
that we then we want to have so there's
a name there's a brief description and
there's an explanation for like how to
fix the issue
maybe there's a severity you know
whether it breaks the build etcetera so
once we have that metadata I'm actually
going to start typing some code here so
one one method to be aware of is called
get applicable method names so the way
lint works is you know there's a couple
options you can either make your own ast
scanner which kind of like just give you
total control you can scan the entire
source file look at what for whatever
you wants for performance reasons we
have these hooks where you can register
with lint like hey I'm only interested
in method calls I have this particularly
name and so here we're actually only
interested in method calls with named
yield and if I have any type of it's not
going to work so you know let me know
once you have that hook in place we have
to write the hook itself so here we can
say visit method and make sure that's
readable for all of you
so this method should really only be
called when we come across a yields
function call in the source code so we
can say like okay let's assert that the
method name we're looking at is actually
yield so this should always be the case
and then because we have type
information we can do due diligence and
make sure that we don't have a false
positive here because maybe there's a
another class with the function called
yields and we want to make sure that
it's actually the you know Java laying
thread dot yield so here we're going to
check we've some helper methods I'll
type it out if you look at the evaluator
you can say is member in class we're
gonna pass it the resolve method node
and then we're going to give the class
name so Java outlaying dot thread this
just means you know if this method that
they're calling is actually part of this
exact class then we can report the error
and then I'll say contacts that report
I'll give it the issue that we holds the
metadata we have above I'll give it the
node I'll give it the location so we're
telling Lintz like hey here's where the
error is this is what you should
highlight and I think I have to give it
the message so let's say please don't
use this obviously you should use some
more helpful error message all right
that's all it takes if I have no typos
I'm going to make make the projects
it's done and if I go back to our
application BAM Lynch has already
scanned your source code it's already
picked up a lint check writing the ID
says please don't use this and that's
really powerful you can make this pop up
for your colleagues and everything so
awesome let's go back to the slides all
right 50 seconds left I'm pretty happy
with the timing here here's some links I
really want you to check these out so if
you've never read like the lint overview
on our developer page please go there
it's got a lot of information both from
this talk and a little bit more please
check out the annotations page I just
touched on like three random examples
but there's so many useful annotations
that can really prevent a lot of bugs
ahead of time before you users ever see
them if you are really excited about
this demo I just gave at the end here
check out the sample project we have on
github where you can actually write your
own custom lint checks and I'll kind of
get you up to speed and finally if you
run into any issues we have a Lynch
mailing list where you can go to for
help many of you might note or he's
pretty active on the mailing list I'm
pretty active on the mailing list you
kind of answered all the questions that
that get asked there all right and with
that thank you so much if you have any
questions I don't ask them now but I'll
be out in the sandbox area afterward and
I'll be happy to answer any questions so
please check out Testament checks thanks
[Applause]
[Music]